[Music]
I've never been diagnosed that I was
like 39 years old and stuff so put that
on me and me my diagnosed diagnosed with
a mental condition Kanye West gets real
about his mental health struggles while
chatting with hosts big boy at his yay
listening party in Wyoming last Thursday
just do something from my heart the next
day the 40 year old rapper dropped his
most revealing and controversial album
yet including cover art that read
I hate being bipolar it's awesome she
does my third perk that's my five pose
what that's my superpower
ain't no disability I'm a superhero I'm
a superhero I'm so blessed and so
privileged because think about people
that have mental issues that are not
Kanye West that can't go and make that
make you feel like it's all good
think about somebody that does exactly
what I did at TMZ and they just do that
at work right but then Tuesday morning
they come in a lost their job yeah and
they can't go back and make that you
know that's why God put that on me Yeezy
did not directly mention his bipolar
diagnosis but you can connect the dots
in the candid sit down I think everybody
got something but like I said on Alma
said is not a disability is a superpower
[Music]
[Applause]